leute was geht hier so erwachsen und
herzlich willkommen zu diesem kleinen
video eigentlich wollte ich heute wieder
gaming bringen ich habe nämlich gestern
mit - du zusammen richtig richtig
richtig richtig richtig richtig richtig
richtig richtig coole sache überlegt was
ihr aufnehmen können zusammen allerdings
hat es nicht geklappt leider
wir haben das gestern erst mal umgesetzt
und heute wollten wir dann eigentlich
aufnehmen
problem war dass franz aber heute super
viel für die schule zu tun gehabt hatten
und wir deshalb keinen gemeinsamen
termin gefunden haben daher wird das
ganze morgen kommen franzens morgen
nicht kommt ein spaß daher wird das
ganze morgen kommen und hier kann ich
darauf freuen ich habe nämlich auch ein
bisschen neues equipment ihr zugelegt
skistadion bildschirm noch und ja
deshalb gibt es das heute nicht es tut
mir sehr sehr leid ich hoffe trotzdem
dass ihr sehr schön sein
und ach so ich frag mich wahrscheinlich
wer ist das franz ruf doch gerade an ich
habe mich so auf laut beschallte falls
ihr noch mal anrufen in dem video hallo
franz du bist gerade in meinem
entschuldigungs video das heute kein
video kommt wie geht's jetzt du dich das
können video kommt heute nein ich hab
schon klar dass du viel für die schule
zu tun gehabt hast machen wir video
übertragen an
oder du sagst sich ja nicht so wie wenn
du nichts dagegen hast egal egal wie ich
mein weil du du machst hier
normalerweise keine face camp und so ach
ja gut leute dann doch kein - tut zeigt
sein wahres gesicht
ok rottmann leistet der kleine fatal
der kleine stücke da ist ja ich finde
jetzt dem bildschirm wo man denn wild
sieht aber das was darauf instagram
pendant ist nicht schlimm
jetzt habe ich mal wieder lange gelagert
ohne inhalt bzw der inhalt ist heute
gibt's das coole video noch nicht dafür
könnt ihr euch um so mehr auf morgen
freuen da wird das geben ich kann es
auch dieses video nicht groß schneiden
leider weil wir in 23 minuten im kino
sein müssen